welcome back to a lot of work right are
so excited to have my next guest every
now and then I get gout about a guest
who you because I'm a fan and you're not
supposed to say that you're supposed to
say admirer so what can you say Colonel
Allen West thank you so much for being
on sir
famous crowd is good to be with you my
friend oh he called me friend look how
sweet is he didn't have to do that but
we'll be sure to stop you an envelope
with unmarked bills after the show so do
you prefer mr. west colonel
professional badass what should i what
should I do here well you know I spent
22 years to earn a certain title and
they're appreciative of it okay well
good that's you know my grandfather was
a colonel in the Air Force wonderful and
I don't know what the rules are but he
was always complaining about the fact
that he I mean he was a colonel for
decades and I guess you had to have a
college degree to make general am I am I
correct well normally is preferred that
you have that college degree in order to
get promoted as a as an officer
definitely you know to the rank of
captain so that's a lot of things about
being commissioned is a requirement for
a four-year college degree yeah well
that must have came in after because he
definitely didn't have that and he made
colonel and I think the the rules were
you know were enacted after and he was
always complaining about it generals and
he was a he was a surly old man but
probably the best fighter pilot in the
country well it was all about his skills
yeah yeah you know what falling off back
then he would have told you that he flew
better after a scotch he was that kind
of guy just drop the bombs I'm okay yeah
exactly sometimes he was a little too
bombed himself but you know it's funny
okay I'm not really funny it's a little
funny but you're a military guy like you
said you've you've been out there you've
been in that this is terrestrial so we
won't use the military term we'll say
crap you've been in the crap what what
do you do when you watch what's going on
right now with Isis and I don't want to
put any words in your mouth I can guess
where you're coming from as far as in a
pain
the president's handling of it I know
where most conservatives line up when
you sit back and watch this what goes
through your mind and I guess what would
you do differently well first of all I
would have recognized the enemy and you
know I would not have allowed back into
being created in in Iraq because
actually what has happened is al Qaeda
in Iraq which had been defeated there
were cables that in communications that
people had intercepted saying that
there's no need for the Brethren to go
into Iraq all was lost but we gave life
back into them so a year ago Isis was
about 3,000 fighters they were called
and referred to the JV team now today
they're close to fifty to sixty thousand
and they have affiliations and about
eleven to twelve different countries
they are brilliant brilliantly using
social media to get their horrific
savage message out to include this
recent one when I think a 10 11 year-old
kids if you know executed a man right
and now we we just had earlier this week
Boko Haram come out and declare their
allegiance so there is a global Islamic
jihadist movement that is happening
right under our noses and we're not
doing anything about it as a matter of
fact what we're doing is decimating our
own military capability and capacity
right now let me ask you this as a
military guy you know a lot of
libertarians will get mad and say that
that you're a war hawk
where do you balance that line between
supporting the military right and in
reducing the scope of government I I'm
99 percent sure what your answer is
going to be in this legitimate but I
know you know listen I got a lot of
tweets with people who are upset about
that libertarians who really just
believe that we're over militarized well
I would tell them that the most
important responsibilities of the
federal government is to provide for the
common defense it is not about right so
many other things that we see the
federal government getting engaged and
involved in so there's a way to develop
a fiscally responsible United States
military we cannot I mean I love it when
people quote George Washington in his
farewell speech well George Washington
could not send me a Twitter post halfway
the world so there's a different
environment that we're in and we have an
enemy that even Thomas Jefferson had to
contend with
during the Barbary wars that is still on
their own March their own I'll be route
their own crusade for the past fourteen
hundred years against Western
civilization now we can continue to I
guess dismiss this enemy this non-state
non-uniformed
unlawful enemy combatant Islamist enemy
but that is not going to cause them to
go away so we have to confront this we
have to deal with it and we've made
several mistakes across several
different administration's that have
brought us to this point right now as an
example you know you have not been shy
to criticize people on both sides of the
aisle a lot of people don't know that
because what gets out in social media is
that steadily picture of you and your
military uniform with the flattop
you pull it off very well sir and so
they think that you're only you know
hardcore military Republican now you
interesting enough you support of the
Patriot Act but then came out and you
know gate gave some insight now now now
you just said something that's incorrect
okay correct me what debate today what
happened was I voted for the three
months extension of the Patriot Act
because you know why would I just go and
show up and say no I wanted to be able
to understand it I sent letters to
director Mueller of the FBI I did my
research and due diligence and when it
came up with full renewal I voted
against it right well yes and I didn't
mean to speak out of turn that's what I
was getting to a lot of people you know
on Twitter just go ask him about is his
war crimes supporting the Patriot Act
and what sticks in my mind is the fact
that you were so vocal and actually
helped educate me
on the Patriot Act in your criticism of
it but that doesn't always get out right
when the leftist media is trying to
paint you in a certain way oh sure
exactly doesn't bother me it doesn't
bother me whatsoever because that's
there Alinsky tactic I mean I know the
truth and and I know what I stood for
and I think that did help to educate a
lot of people about the provisions of
the Patriot Act can be able to talk
specifically about instances why it
should not be renewed and of course that
was something that you know other
members in the
republican party to include the then
chairman of the permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence Mike Rogers
out of Michigan he really tried to push
me hard and I said you can't get my vote
on this because you know I haven't fear
achill you know dad improved it it's not
doing what we have to go to a break real
quick but there is no more steadily move
than that we'll be right back with Alan
West so sorry to cut you off Cornel West
mr. colonel Alan West because you're
making a good point and listen I will
tell you this when it comes to the
Patriot Act actually you know reading
the transcripts of some of the things
that you had spoken about certainly
helped educate me on the issue and
that's always why I bring it up I think
that I think anyone who has a history of
being in the military listen it's it's
no secret that leftist are inherently
you know anti-military in a way that
they don't want to admit or maybe even
in a way that they don't necessarily
realize do you feel like sometimes
considering you know what what asteroid
career you've had you feel like
sometimes you're a little bit
pigeon-holed maybe in the Republican
Party as the military guy when you have
more to offer ah not really I think the
best part of you know the the
politicized media world that we're in
people try to define you and waste and
makes them comfortable but right I
believe that my profile is pretty broad
enough that and when you look at my
position now is the president CEO the
National Center for Policy Analysis you
know the ability to be able to talk
about tax policy or entitlement pension
reform policies monetary policies
regulatory education energy health care
as well as national security you know I
am able to you know really show that I
have a broad-based understanding
probably a lot better than some of the
people sitting in in Washington DC right
now so I don't get concerned about how
people try to just you know really make
you for their own comfort level because
you know that's one of the successes I
think of the alum V West comm site where
we light on many different issues right
ya know you're absolutely right it's a
kernel alan west the Chuck Norris of
politics he just doesn't know about that
Chuck Norris
do I actually have to tell you I ready
to Chuck Norris at my uncle's Country
Club in Dallas I just walked into a room
it was some Easter thing I'm not a
country club guy I know I'll get the
hate mail right now for people watching
online you're a country club Republican
you know the same thing the pigeonholing
and I walked into a room out of just the
only person in the room was Chuck Norris
it was like a banquet room and he was
sitting there at a table and I mean I
know the Machado brothers we've you know
we've trained them a he's a black belt
in jujitsu in judo but I tell you what
you could fit Chuck Norris in your back
pocket he is not a large man I was very
surprised so all I'm saying is if it
comes down to you and Chuck my money
would be on the colonel that's all I'm
saying okay hopefully I don't see him in
the dark Alex well hopefully listen
we're all friends here he's a good guy
oh yeah he's great guy let me ask you
this okay so obviously listen you're
you're a black American you're not
expected to be conservative right I mean
Alphonso Rachel a good friend of mine
I've just read through some of the mail
that he gets and it's it's absolutely
heart-wrenching do you know like you
offer perspective that many people out
there maybe miss with right now you know
the narrative is police brutality hands
up don't shoot I mean where do you live
on that and where do you think maybe
Republicans and liberals but both miss
it well it's interesting enough because
when you go back and you read the
writings of Booker Colossus and the
great southern black educator right at
the turn of the century and he had a
three-point principle or plan and it was
education entrepreneurship and
self-reliance and so when you think
about those three principles those are
not progressive socialist principles
those are conservative principles and
when you you know think about what the
the the bedrock of the black community
always has been faith family you know
education which was stressed in my
household even you know service to the
nation I mean my lineage goes all the
way back to my bed and served in World
War two and older brother in Vietnam and
now my nephew is a major serving so when
you you know we just need to have that
conversation about principles with the
black community when you think about
what progressive socialist policies
done to the black community you know 16
million black babies aborted you know
the decimation of the black family too
now you only have 28 percent of black
children have mother and father in the
home that's what we open up the
conversation when bill de blasio the
mayor of New York and about socialist
wanted to cancel the charter school
problems in New York City one of the
highest performing charter schools in
New York City is in Harlem and it's
called Success Academy and it was single
black mothers who made the complaint to
the local of New York saying don't do
this you know this is an opportunity for
our children so there is the the ability
to have the kind of concern of
conversation and this is not something
new it's not some trend that a lot of
people want to say and and I think that
you know I hate the word outreach the
Republican party needs to ban that word
they need to talk about policy
inclusiveness and I think they'll go far
right I don't necessarily exactly I
don't think you need to sermonize or
like you said conduct outreach it's
really just about being relevant and and
being there just be there right yeah
yeah and you know I mean think about
what happened in Ferguson Missouri was a
black teenager who is part of a
demographic that has a 40 percent
unemployment rate he comes from an area
I guarantee there's a failed public
school so all of those opportunities
that diminished there is no small black
small black business entrepreneurship
that is going on in fact those 25
businesses that they burn down in
Ferguson they're not coming back and so
it's the lack of opportunity is not our
hands up don't shoot that's the
low-hanging fruit that the left wants to
use along with the Voting Rights thing
and all of that they don't want to talk
about the real issues that are
afflicting the black community today and
really the Intercity and you know all
minority community
so we need to have that conversation
yeah I think that's a really good point
let me ask you point-blank you talk
about leftist you know media who are
reaching for that low-hanging fruit and
they're creating this sort of racial
division do you think our president
proactively Stokes those fires of course
she does because that is the Saul
Alinsky way you know whether they want
versus 99% war women black puss is like
anything that they can use to you know
promote the collective vision instead of
respecting them regard of the individual
and that's the difference between what
Liberty is or what tyranny is right no
that's a great point and gosh I'm sure
you've seen the LAPD tape right the LAPD
shooting you've been following that yeah
well if you haven't seen the tape then
it you know it was a situation where
there was a a an illegal alien convicted
bank robber or wanted I know by the u.s.
marshals I think he was convicted and
they went down an answer to call tased
the guy didn't work he swung on a cop
someone took a cop's nightstick there
was five of them you know lining up to
whack on the back that the guy got shot
and you know I watched the videotape
it's always I'm amazed now that our
standards are so low that you can
actually see the death circulatin news I
don't know about you I remember there
was a time where the rule was you
couldn't actually show anyone died and
now it seems like we see that all the
time which is a sad state of ours you
know in our culture but the media that
the media isn't that narrative kind of
like Ferguson I mean did you see did you
see that where you like me maybe just
screaming at your TV going just wait
until the information comes in are we in
an age where people just don't wait and
it's because everything is politically
motivated well of course it is and when
you think about how the the left try to
use Ferguson to stoke the fires to get
you know blacks to come out and vote you
know if you down in Georgia if you vote
for the blood the white guy running for
Senate David Perdue you could have a
Ferguson happen in your your a your
neighborhood and community you know
pictures of lynchings will put on cars
that black churches on Sunday before the
election in North Carolina yes people
are going to use anything they can to
stoke those fires and you think about
the president and how he is on several
occasions jump the gun would be the skip
gates incident up there in in Boston at
Cambridge University I mean at Harvard
in Cambridge right now to choose this
you know this is what people have to do
because they can't talk about their
policies
they can't talk about really what they
stand for so what they have to always do
I call it the Kansas City shuffle don't
mean you look like they go left they put
the deception up there they put the
shiny thing up there for you to pay
attention to and you never really pay
attention to their their true motives
and and objectives and goals it sounds
to me like you're just racist Cornel
West how dare you come on this show and
spew that kind of hate speak we don't
allow it it's funny you know I get this
all the time all the time if you just
speak about these issues of course
unless you line up with the social media
narrative you're immediately accused of
being a racist or a bigot
do you experience that as much as a
black American car of course you're
going to get the year and Uncle Tom your
sellout white man sports monkey or you
get it all I've never heard that on air
but continue please no but let's see the
thing is that's an indicator that you're
winning the debate right when they have
to you know when they are relegated to
that level of despicable name-calling
and denigrating you and just the same as
I tell you know white Americans when
they call your races you can't
self-censor because that is the
Pavlovian response that you that you
have been given giving them and so
that's what I continue to use it no you
can't you can't shut up you have to
continue to talk about the issues and
continue to talk about the points look
you know I don't hear anyone coming out
and praising the president for the
University of Oklahoma for the swift
action he took against that fraternity
down there right I mean he as soon as he
found out he gave him 24 hours and and
he should be praised for that because he
is not tolerating that type of thing
right no that's a good point do you
think you know saying that seeing as
you're someone who's who's able to look
at both sides critically do you think
the right plays into it a little too
easily sometimes even a nun right oh
yeah yeah I mean there are times when
you know we go into what we call in the
military the u-shaped ambush and we have
to be smarter about that but then again
I would say you cannot allow the the
left to to always fall back on
that age-old saying you know you don't
like him because he's black I mean you
know Eric Holder was not a good Attorney
General because of this game called he
was not a good Attorney General because
he was deceitful
he told lies and he was not a fair
adjudicator of justice and he even said
that he once said that he took pride in
being a social activist so that's why he
was not appreciating you know we still
don't know about fast and furious I know
it's very hard to get your plus plus
let's be honest the real reason is is
Eric Holder looks like Ned Flanders and
I find that offensive you know okay so
we talk about this we talk about I mean
I'm sure you get these questions all the
time and people asking these questions
race related questions and I'm sorry to
be another one but you know I think with
my audience it's a younger audience on
YouTube and terrestrial eat it they'll
want to hear this let me ask you this I
don't get super political on the show
all the time because people just harp on
the same thing it gets to be old but
you're a guy who knows his stuff here
really well what would you say are the
biggest you know the winningest issues
for conservatives right now in America
what should they focus on is the the
preeminence of the individual their
rights and their liberty and the
equality of opportunity as opposed to
the collective vision of equality of
outcomes that's that is the clear
separation between who we are and who
they are the fact that they they believe
not in the pursuit of happiness as
opposed to a guarantee of happiness and
that guarantee of happiness comes from
the government and when you talk about
our young people the thing that our
young people need to come to understand
is that their future is at risk when you
look at their futures for us their
economic security and their future as
far as their national security and and
and and so that should be something that
we should easily be able to convict well
you have young people and and I have a
daughter 21 will be graduating from
college and may when you have young
people that are leaving college and they
have to go back and stay at home with
mommy and daddy because there's no job
opportunities out there for them and
they have immense amount of debt that's
not the American dream and so you know
we need to talk again about
the shining city this apana hill how
we're going to do that which Americans
have always done to ensure that a better
and brighter future is ahead for you
know the subsequent generations that's
how you have a mother and father my dad
was born in 1920 my mother in 1931 down
so in George and Alabama and look at
where I am today it's because they cared
about my future and and we need to make
that clear delineation that we have a
vision for for this country for this
constitutional republic the other side
doesn't what a great point what a great
way to leave it and for the people
listening even if you take Cornel West
advice it doesn't mean that you'll be
able to pull off the high and tight as
well as he does as well as he put it so
be careful there are very few who could
wear it well you sir thank you so much
you've been a fantastic guest and really
pretty taking the time Allen West click
my face to subscribe right now I wish it
were a better looking face or watch this
previous video you might enjoy it you
might not but at that point you've
already clicked it so I don't really
care